hi I'm Alan scores coming this is the
first time I'm speaking a multi-track
conference may that's an extra level of
insanity right whether your your room
will be empty by the time you show up
here so thank you very much for choosing
me over the rest I'm really grateful and
I hope it it's worth worth your time
today I'm going to talk about a very
specific functionality very specific
Bibles so we are going to look at a very
small thing take it apart and see how it
works and this is probably not the
typical often you get abused at this
conferences and things are more of a
structure and great picture there are
two results why why actress in this the
first is that I know it relatively well
some of the things that I'm going to
talk you about I I compute the Delta
vendors and others ISO 400 and use them
somewhere so so I have a pretty good
understanding of how watching both most
of what I'm going to talk about works
but the reason I is those contributions
is especially because I think is super
cute and super nice and pretty and it's
still and that should be reason enough
to to look at it and hopefully you go
from here with the same warm particulate
that IDs when I when I look at this
campus like a clever taken other people
have come up before we get into into the
gory details of I have to tell you I
would like for us to pause for a minute
and consider that the reason that we can
have a talk my place is because Tundras
is an open source project if it were an
open source I wouldn't have had a chance
the source code you probably wouldn't be
users of it and there would be no reason
to sit here in a room and be talking
about how these are implemented in an
open-source little right and I mean it's
nice and how to talk about contributions
and how there needs to be a lot of
overturn in in people participating and
I would like for you to help them and
basically encourage you to try to do
your part in making open-source people
if you think you like the time or
continue like the skills will sing again
if anyone think they are label if you
want to sit with me for 20 minutes you
liquor being not like contributor
numbers commit to the membership area
that's a it's not yes T yes talk to me
later afterwards and I will make it
happen right and you really really don't
have time well there's some focus there
so we get money freedom focus right you
don't want to put in your eyes put put
your money will we want you yes yes I
see how much time you have is that mean
well by now can say no I'm here until
Monday nights ago that's perfect
yeah I hope I don't have to be great
what are you so so what if this is
rolling personality that I'm I'm telling
you about so it is an object that you
can construct on a hundred serious or
that afraid that can efficiently compute
aggregations of going to use and I
underline deficient because that's
basically why kids good is that it does
it very very well
well as it can be done
if available for serious and for data
frames and it's very similar it has a
close passing that will expand and I
have this you know some of that I have
this little toy of if we have an array
with these five items and we want
summation point in summary there is it
anyway if we have an array with with
pile items or successors like this and
we want to do some window for items this
is the way we would be revolving that
window over over our data and we would
have a view on which we want to do some
kind of fabrication will actually
relation again something finding out the
minimum or the maximum or the mean of
the standard variation or the media or
something like that
and actually in the table we're gonna
look at something which is the same as
in other reducer that I thought about
minimum maximum variance and median
those are the things that we are going
to go into into the debate and I'm
virtually onwards here so I have a
little notebook and you said magical
ship and
okay so we port unless we're going to
look at some yes sir so we have multiple
pivot line and we're going to try to
import the birth year land and ocean
data set here
so this is a little when it was first
introduced a few years ago it was
probably the first air temperature data
set that no one can put complain about
all which sayest it's wrong it's being
paid by the government that want to
steal our money to spend it in
preventing climate change right so it
was like the first comprehensive data
set that it was really really hard to
complain about its fairness without
making a fool of yourself but this is
probably ten years ago so basically what
I download it here is a record of the
anomaly which is different from the mean
over some reference time of the global
temperature by one since the beginning
of 1800 1850 so that's a lot of time I'm
gonna only look at the last thirteen
seven years right so since nineteen
eighty we want to have an index that
it's a date and it will look at the last
values here yet so there's only until
until much we haven't updated data for
for for the last couple moons or glass
mountains anyway so this is what the
temperature won't by mom looks for the
last fifty seven years
interesting thing there's some seasonal
variation even though it's a global
other it's because there's mall at
Portland on the northern hemisphere in
the south so the whole world has more of
a summer when it's summer is one of the
two places in ten
it is right now but you could say that
one side of the world will set the other
investor in place word like that yeah
this is Bible people want to look at it
over years we would say give me rolling
information on your data with a
four-month window okay so this is yes an
object on which we can say okay for the
anomaly data set do you think the means
and we get us in without their channel
on the previews they if you followed
Adam oh yeah people have weird interest
or some time in my life I sort of follow
this whole climate skepticism prophecy
out there this they circle more or less
like a few years before this hitch life
is the warming hiatus or he warming
costs where it was real proof that and
we're trying to see our money the
government and the old companies were
not present that yet sooner anyway you
can also compute the maximum in and we
can look at Cheerilee temperature
differences we could decide to see
variation not with the rate at the
December radiation and we could do
things like well I'm not really
interested in nearly averages give me
something even smoother the choose
trends nicer five years so sixty months
and we get again the same very very
clearly over the 40 plus 40 years almost
a degree of increase in in global
temperature right that if I tonight but
if you want to use the media because
maybe it's different it's the more or
less the same the same message that you
if you get across they're still response
here that unfortunately it has gone
speed up or applies to us to do okay so
but
my cool it is and if you came to my
virtual yesterday we explained how to
get slicing window views on on a race so
why would you make and us for any of
these right you we have a dataset here
which is again six numbers 0 1 2 3 4 5
we do this magic incantation in non
fight and we get an array that has the
first window the second window and the
third window on that paper set and then
we can compute the sum by this running
sum on the on the on the last axis of
that array and get 6 which is the
someone first item paying important so
it's rolling others right and this is
interesting because there was actually
some discussion recently on a fight
about we should provide a function that
does this kind of sliding window easy to
do forward for people and I think it's
about a year because this is dangerous
because it gives you a false sense of
knowing what you're doing and there's
this thing that computer scientists use
that is called Big O notation that is
used to think about how much work you
have to do or the computer is going to
have to do to compute something that you
must fit and if we look at this array
and we say that well there are six items
which have we're going to call N and we
have a window for which we're going to
call em in this case you have to do one
two three additions 4 5 6 7 8 9 so
computing all these three values has
required us having making night
additions if you work out the math that
comes out to n minus n plus 1 times n
minus 1 which for all practical purposes
is dominated by n X n so this is n n
right and this is typically not good
when you have to look at your data
one time there's saw that the strong
came that there's probably a better way
of weeding right and there's that great
course on algorithms like tim
roughgarden on Coursera or she keeps
asking and we the rhetoric and we do
better and it's good to have that in the
back of your mind
even though Parekura optimization is the
root of all evil
some kind of initiation is is good to
have in mind and let that the base thing
is that if you've decided on a long
window list and blow up remember you you
want to do a window of sixty items moved
upon the size of your data it's very
large by 60 is probably not regulating
okay so the basic insight that allows
you to do this thing efficiently is this
right that when you slide your window
most of your data stays the same
you're actually only getting rid of an
item and adding another one right so if
you could somehow know how to give you
all the cooperation so but yes take one
thing I'll throw another in and
completely new aggregation easily well
you would say a lot of time right and so
this is like the big explanation even
knowing this I think that the only one
person have talked about the salvage
you're thinking of computing the sum and
they tell you what about in YouTube is
is like oh yes I know how to do it right
I have one - strategy and we're going to
that's probably that's the only one that
I think if I want to let them out on an
island with this to work on for the rest
of my life I might get the Sun without
knowing what is the rest I don't think
I'll ever and will ever come up with
them so yeah you have to trust other
smarter people when you that have come
across it that make you feel clever by
understanding how they were clip if that
make sense
right so as I was saying sounds are very
easy if you have the running somewhere
window the next window is going to be at
the acting that's coming in you
subscribe to one that comes out of the
window you get the new sound over there
over the full array this is the actual
number of work that you do so it's
basically to put two additions per item
linear it's of the same order of the
number of packets and this really this
is as smooth as it gets like you cannot
do much later than look at the item once
or twice and come up with with what you
want you cannot do you cannot not look
at all the items to compute the rolling
time right now the thing is it it does
get better because and this is where
these ideas that you might not have
followed out ever may come in handy for
something that you do completely
different and the idea here is that if
you have a series like this you can
create another way which is the
accumulated sample of a cycle so you
have a fear of the beginning that we
have 0 plus 0 is 0 plus y is 1 plus 2 is
3 plus 3 is 6 plus 4 is 10 plus 5 is 15
plus 6 is 21 and if we now wanted to
compute the sum on any window whatsoever
over originally we just have to get one
item is on the end the item of the
reading
distracted right so 15 minus 1 is 14 15
minus 3 would be 12 so the sum of 3 4 5
okay
and I mean this is Wow sorry they didn't
sugar excited it is it is super cool
that you can do some work store it
somewhere and then be able to compute
anything yeah well I mean I find it very
cool
cut anything it is and aside from the
coolness it has practical applications
right because you can do the same thing
in more than one language if you have a
limits and you compute this if you
compute the sum over the rows and the
columns so like this body fear 16 is the
sum of everything in this opponent here
right now if we want to compute the sum
over an area it works out to we ask this
number with this one and we subtract
these two now the idea that this number
is the sum of everything in this
favorite angle so we need to take out
these two extra parts that without so we
subtract this which removes this we
subtract this which will look this but
oh we subtracted one twice so we need to
remove the one that we have here will
get worried by so that we have the whole
thing this is actually called inclusion
exclusion principle it's a general
concept in what the general concept and
it's good to have it in mind
if you've ever tried to solve project
Euler problems one of the first is about
computing the multiples of 3 & 5 but not
of 15 or something or sub 3 or 5 0 and
you have to use an illusion illusion
that's another practical implementation
this is so useful that it's the method
of this slice mathematicians program
some variables image processing people
called an interval images and inverse a
key part of EBL ideally detection
algorithm which is what happened around
the beginning of the century when all of
a sudden your camera wasn't taking
places right and you started seeing
those tiny squares around faces in your
images it was this algorithm at work in
the in the background well plus plus
some other side yes the text that was a
big part of it okay so yeah latex this
must be a good pot right if we if we
look at the the rolling variant you
might remember this wrong from
statistics or not but you can compute
the variance like this where in the end
you have the sum of the squares and the
squares of the sound right so because we
already know how to compute a momentum
if we keep rolling sounds on X and x
squared we could compute the barriers on
a rolling window by doing this operation
on those and here having something
relatively interested and you might
think of this as a next up paper set
because we have a base value off with a
video and we're running a random noise
of plus minus 1 to it or plus 1 to it
but the thing is is we compute the
variance with this formula we get a
negative number and the variance set up
in
it's a sum of squares right and this is
the kind of thing that makes your coat
start giving square root of a negative
number hours and it looks really bad and
yes no one's happy and that has happened
to me in real so computing variance
Rogge and having this happening what's
going on fear is that floating point
numbers have a limited position and if
you have a number that can potentially
be very big which is this sport here you
may lose the slot vidiots of the
difference and all of a sudden paper it
down and you get a negative number okay
and that's that's not good
this what's my first illusion dependence
changing that to this one I'm
emotionally attached to it
so and this is a kind of magic that you
will figure out yourself in in a million
years right
this dial well for the fifties of
America came up with the fact that you
cannot take immediate need of a number
on the sum of squares from the
difference using these formulas if you
take a pen and paper and start working
about they do work they also happen to
be very very constraining so but it
allows us to if I have the mean and the
sum of squared differences from the mean
over data set I can add one other number
to those and compute the new Coco right
once you have that it's very easy to go
it's easier to turn this around and say
instead of a Lima number I'm going to
remove one and then we already have the
building blocks for when we move our
window we have one - remove another okay
wikipedia has a wonderful article on
algorithm for calculating the variance
which explains a lot of this stuff about
the same time that I'm making changes to
- unless someone it edited the Wikipedia
page to add this idea it's also possible
to remove data from from the set and
compute the new variance and today added
the formula and they even have a it
wasn't here promise they have a formula
for when I have one and I remove one
this is how to do it but it lasted for a
couple of months because apparently that
qualifies as original research so if
anyone wants to send a paper for
mathematical journal or this stuff we
might get in Python periods of people
can come find addition but right now you
have to search the archive storm two
thousand thirteen or fourteen to find
that information of its variation which
is no longer no longer there thing to
keep on the back of your life about this
is that you can use the same idea rather
than twice a single item to join to
write beta cells so this lets you
paralyze or enhance computations and
there are similar formulas or kurtosis
and skewness and any higher-order bone
so you could potentially use ideas like
this to speed up our lives computations
on on very large data set but yeah and
so from here o things are probably going
to get even weirder because the
cleverness grows up very very very tough
so to compute the ruling minimum and
maximum other is a very clever algorithm
is linear again so yeah we especially
say that that last algorithm is doing a
constant amount of work in every step so
in
being senior right for me one a maximum
there is some very very smart algorithm
the original source seems to be the blog
of my data Cobra channel hunter who died
15 years ago but you have a huge amount
of writings and some people decided to
preserve and there's a richer Tartarus
world or something like that this is the
actual description of the algorithm but
the whole thing is is go if you're bored
one day go there and and have fun I
guess
alright get back to my name here now the
first guys who learn the obvious was
indeed seafood one is the alpha of
bottleneck open make is a library that
this is cycle to speed up some
computations on ocean on memories that
was copied to pandas and I saw it from
pandas and you step inside hi in the
image okay and it uses a kind of
specialized data structure are is
actually called a big which is a data
structure you not only have starts when
you put late a problem
once I am moved from this inside you
have tombs were things going here and go
out there and the queue should be able
to get data in and out promote side
right I'm naturally unexplained you so
if this is our set on which we want to
compute the minimum we have this is our
double ended queue was set like the one
at the beginning and it's red because
it's the minimum we go to the next
nightmare and say all three it's not
your than one so when one goes out if
they become the human so we're sorry
taking happens before because it's
lighter than the numbers before it may
eventually be the minimum and so happens
with six when we move here to the next
step one is already out
preacher is it yes and fire as you play
6 because 6 can never be the minimum
because 5 is already ok and we keep
going like this and the interesting
thing is that because we are not needing
this values anymore we can sort of reuse
those as if the end here was collective
this and you have your DQ store is
something that looks like a ring yeah I
thought this would make more sense the
successor of an ex-slave
let's go and find anyway it's also hard
to see but this is linear and there's a
wonderful explanation in that make that
I have over there you have to trust me
in math because I have community through
your businesses ok this is this is scope
I mean if you like like this kind of
low-level details looking at the pocket
and I wrote for this it's it's a
wonderful experience present and lastly
we have the rolling media so if you two
mediums the simple way to ascertain a
key item in the middle that's typically
or when log n which is not that fun
you can get very clear and very
complicated and alert in all n quick
select algorithm ledesma to get the same
functionality on a rolling window
requires I'd say if I specialized a
structure with the six are and enhance
skills this is actually a dimension of
Raven container one of the core
developers of numpy is the actor helper
of the collections of the old world and
I think also of the one
I yes yes so he's a very smart guy and
he came up with a way of doing this you
know and log em the window okay so this
is reasonably fast one interesting thing
about this is that it uses randomization
for efficiency so if you're really
really unlucky your performance may may
say but nobody is so unlucky all the
time sort of the at the idea evangelist
so it's in practice it works a sibling
must look like this so we have our first
onions and we've certainly not in a
linked list right we have a way of
getting from one month to the next in
order if I wanted to find the medians
here and we'll have to start at the
beginning count until I get there that's
a lot of work so what how is like
expresslanes up here let's let you get
to a point further down the road so it's
probably easier to see we remove the
window by one step we have to remove the
six so it's long here but we have to add
the time and the way we will do will
quantify this we would say oh this is a
one there's nothing after here one or we
can get to pour so five is our girl and
of course I'm going to come here this is
the end so now I go by and I take this
is six so it has to go in the middle
here but instead of blowing all the way
I've gone through a stress line and if
you found the damage it's actually
faster to build out but that's yes
because this is a very small example
like in the Darrell idea that you have
like this experience you know a lot
about calls on highways around here
right so which is also tightened on how
this work and now what you do is you
bother dividing here but to decide if
you are expert links to it you click
upon and here with the unlikely and the
clip exploits so we've added two extra
Express lanes to it so when we move to
the next item we're going to remove the
three at the seven
the 3-stone we've added to sit in the
same way this time with good headaches
one so we learn as an icon fear there's
none here so we're gonna go here and we
keep doing that right and maybe now we
click head at the beginning and yes
there's no this whole structure remains
efficient on an average sense some of
the iterations may not develop the long
run to expect it to be more or less
efficient all the time and that's what
what you count on to get this
oh and Logan performance or the media
and that's all I have and we can have
yes time for questions I think maybe so
when you're talking about the Sun I've
introduced this community so yes which
reduces the number of operations that
reaches on the problem which is that you
have to get some more memories yes
so how much of a problem is this and how
we deal with it well it actually they
said that it's all the same sizes
originally so that's basically not too
bad and that depends on many things but
things are fun and that happens with not
a lot when you have to get the square
root of your statements set in memory to
do something fun and your state is going
to go down the drain because of that but
in some situations this is very fast and
and again it is even the largest image
that you can take with a camera right
now when you translate it into actual
pixels they're ridiculously small for
or what a modern computer can do so so
in this case it's an operator I mean
people are doing this all the time with
images without even thinking about if
you have millions of or video titles
then maybe it's before it's typically
not not a problem conversions
and thank you for the book a meeting in
I understood that you have 50% chance of
having the proper result or on opening
an expert slate in this when you have
these expresslanes
and when you add an item you flip a coin
to decide if you are I don't know and
exit on that highway to get to the body
thank you and and you keep giving it a
50% chance so we will have half of them
because one here
25% okay we will have one here and so
half of them will again on average you
may be really unlikely and you may add
extra strains for everything and then
it's crap I mean you should go to a
casino man if you're that kind of person
in the universe you know what
[Applause]